Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here!
You're watching!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Happy Tuesday, everybody.
Happy Twosday.
[ Laughter ]
-Ahh, yes.
-With a "W."
'Cause -- yeah, "Twosday"
because it's Tuesday 2-22-22.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, this only happens once
every 100 years.
President Biden was like,
"I didn't care then.
I didn't care now."
I --
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
Speaking of the President --
[ Laughter ]
Biden gave a speech
at the White House
and said that Russia's invasion
of Ukraine has officially begun.
Biden didn't mean to say that,
but Putin invaded
his teleprompter, too.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Yeah, Biden said, "We will not
put up with Russian aggression,
especially on such an important
national holiday, 'Twosday.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's 2-2 --"
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Biden also used his speech
to announce a bunch
of new sanctions against Russia.
Yeah, nothing stops a dictator
in his tracks
like raising his ATM fees.
Yeah, of course.
[ Laughter ]
Russia was like,
"We get two hours of sunlight
and eat potatoes every meal.
What are you going to take away?
What are you going
to take away from us?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is going viral.
A journalist in Ukraine
was reporting the news
on the Russia crisis
in six different languages
and nailed it.
Check this out.
-There's been a war
with Russian-backed forces.
[ Speaking Luxembourgish ]
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Speaking Portuguese ]
[ Speaking French ]
[ Speaking German ]
-Whoa.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
He also knows
six different ways to say,
"I'm ready to leave Ukraine now.
Okay?"
[ Laughter ]
"We can make this a Zoom."
Yeah, it's all good.
Some news --
Some news here in the U.S.
A woman running for Congress
in Oklahoma has apologized
after she mixed wine
and sleep medication,
yelled at a bunch of
12- and 13-year-old girls
at a sleepover, and then
threw up in one of their shoes.
[ Laughter ]
The kids at the sleepover
were torn.
They didn't know whether to help
her or film it for TikTok.
They were like, "Aah!"
[ Laughter ]
"Aah! This is too good."
Yeah, well, after --
Guys, after 25 years,
PBS just aired
the final episode of "Arthur."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
I know.
And it showed
all the characters as adults.
Can we see
what Arthur looks like --
this is real --
all grown up?
[ Laughter ]
Can we see that again?
This is -- yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, he grew up
to be your weed dealer.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Finally, guys,
this is kind of odd,
but a new study found
that Viagra could be
a life-changing drug for dogs.
[ Laughter ]
It's pretty wild,
but it's inspired Viagra
to come up
with some new slogans.
Here, check some of these out.
First up, there's,
"Viagra..."
[ Laughter ]
Next up there's, "Viagra..."
And finally, there's,
"Viagra..."